when did you know ken griffey jr. was
gonna be special
oh he was in the locker room he was the
biggest thief that we stole everything
out of my locker he would he would come
in all of a sudden something be missing
and and they'll and it used to look like
you know I don't know what you're
talking about he and his brother Craig
yeah but there you go and if you left
your locker empty it had anything in it
it was gone well what were they taken it
would be batting gloves it would be you
know anything shirts whatever okay so
you knew he was gonna be a boolean light
but what do you know he's gonna flee at
high school he was talked about
Moeller I mean just there wasn't
anything he couldn't do you know you've
I went it to a pool one day and he's
doing these backflips and stuff and
diving like he's the most natural kid
you ever saw in your life he was a good
football player too oh he could do it
all and the thing that I think about
Kenny was that he didn't want to be it
he just wanted to play he didn't want
the spotlight he didn't even when he
went to Seattle he just sort of slid
under it when he got to Cincinnati was a
second coming of God yeah you know when
he got traded back there yeah it's just
really you know he was he just wanted to
be Kenny he was just one of the nicest
guys you liver and most talented guys
you've ever seen but don't you see that
with Mike Trout that I don't think trout
wants to be I think he just what he's
trying to keep his the best he wants to
be himself but we want him to be bigger
than the sport right and I don't think
he embraces that no I better you know
for what he does and the way he carries
himself I think it's phenomenal for what
how he does it yeah because he could if
he wanted to but somehow they upbringing
the parents the whatever the his
environment was always so special to him
than he respected that
you know I it in 1966 I was in Carolina
League and they asked me about what I
wanted to do and I said well I talked
about the fear of failure in 1966 but it
wasn't failing myself it was failing all
of those people back home all those
people that believed in me all those
people that picked up a newspaper you
know I couldn't imagine something
happening I did something in my parents
had to face what they you know anyway
and I talked about that and I and I just
think that Mike Trout is to me the
epitome
of what baseball players are I mean it's
just so humble and so great and so
talented he hits the ball he ducks his
head he runs and you know he doesn't try
to show anybody up and and I were
blessed with a lot of great talent I
mean we were seeing that I mean some fun
stuff last night at the at the at the
Home Run Derby and people said did you
ever have a homerun Derby
I said yeah every game and so here we re
Cubs right Paulie 1965 was my high
school night last year the number the
scout for the Chicago Cubs name was
Billy Capps and he loved me he loved me
he wanted me so badly and he brought a
his supervisor down and I went 1 for 4
and he stay over stay over we just got
back from a senior trip stay over he
said I can't so the next time I went
four for four with two doubles two home
runs and the Cubs decided they tried to
draft me in the third round
I haven't good Joe I'm gonna go jump out
the window you know but think about I
mean not to be that Hundley cuz they
move me up quickly I could have been you
know I could have been 22 or 23 by the
time I got in the major we would have
been patient mr. Bench we needed yes
Randy Hundley was underrated though oh
he was rody he and grody did he teach
you to put your hand behind your back
now I just I broke my thumb twice but it
found out yeah and I'm thinking you know
this is stupid and it's hard to miss
that thumb I don't know if you'd say
there's some right it's hard to miss
that and I broke it twice and I said
this is stupid and I saw Randy had
caught like 160 games and he was using
it so when I got there I just stuck my
hand down and stuck it out of the way
and I never had another broken bone on
my right hand it was but it was just
something I had to do and I have a book
called catch every ball how did I handle
life's pitches and I kids people come up
to me and say my kid wants to be a
catcher what I tell them let's catch
every ball if you learn to catch every
ball the same thing in life but catching
every ball all of a sudden say man this
guy can really catch him or this lady
can really catch did you have knuckle
balls I'm trying to think who your
we had a guy named Ella Bree Gatewood
Gatewood and Triple A in 1967 and he was
a journeyman and he was on the way out
so he said he throw the knuckleball
I mean it was embarrassing
I don't care I don't care how good a
hands you are this thing is dodging and
bumping on and so all Bree didn't make
it and I came to the major leagues and I
did it and I was very good I went along
no knuckleballers and Sparky called me
in the office one day smarty Anderson
the manager
oh yeah the great he said John we have a
chance to trade for Negro what do you
think I said thank you better trade for
his catcher Johnny Bench we're back
after this and the Dan Patrick show
hall-of-famer Johnny Bench Big Red
Machine joining us here in the man cave
it is weird though you get to this point
in in this in my career where you start
to meet people that you watched on TV or
you looked up to and I don't know our
age difference here but it's like
meeting you meeting Jerry West meeting
some of these people and it's like feel
the same way he's Algeria does show I'm
telling you you know the physique from
cabman qicang then i found that he
doesn't like to be called zeke you know
I read his book West by West yes and and
you didn't like it he dealt with a lot
of different things and everything else
but I mean he was still in that blue
blazer on the end oh he still looks
crummy and it was GQ all the way and I
mean it was just because when I'm his
kid in the gym you know shooting hot rod
Hundley yeah Jerry West and so you still
I mean I'm still in awe of a lot of
these guys in that you know it I'm 70
years old
in December I asked a lady friend of
mine I said do I look 70 and she said no
but you used to
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
help me remember this story about doc
Ellis against the Big Red Machine so doc
Ellis was pitching for the Pirates in
Pittsburgh and he was trying to hit
every member of the well he had taken
LSD cause he wanted to see what it was
like to pick on pitch on LSD but did you
know that there was something off about
well after he got first three guys and
missed me twice yeah we you know I'm
going like this he hit the first three
guys and then I ducked twice you know
and then they came out and took him out
and then you later found that he was
well that's what he told right that's
where we were told ya that he sort of
said that he thought it was a good idea
to try it but did anybody think about
going to the mound going after it no
that was what we did every every series
you know we fought every series
brewskies and Candelaria is a great
rivalry oh it's unbelievable and they
were good no they were really good if we
don't if we're not there the Big Red
Machine is not there Pittsburgh would
have been known as one of the great
teams period they were that good I mean
they had Hebner and ed Robertson they
had Clemente and Stargell yeah now
Oliver could hit yeah Clemente I try to
tell people that there was a
gracefulness about Clemente thank you
had a great arm so oh and he when I
break with him in Puerto Rico and and
wonderful yeah he was a hypochondriac
man well I say that but I think you just
didn't want to go warm up I think you
just didn't care about it cuz he played
this season he played hard yeah but we'd
be in there he'd be in the training and
then in the game would start and he
would like put on the Cape and fly over
and jump over buildings and he was
turning around and throwing it from the
fence and a hundred miles an hour and a
great team mate just you know so sad but
but stars you went Stargell now you had
certain guy Frank Howard was six seven
like you have Erin judge now but Frank
Harry was a big dude Willie Stargell was
a big dude Willie McCovey bullying
McGovern I couldn't imagine being a
first baseman when Stargell or McCovey
came to the players don't some about the
metal bats we saw yes Goods last night
yeah launching it in the back roads and
everything else and that was I loved
that
love those kids they just went up there
and just right out yeah I mean it just
wasn't any hesitation and here you got
the major leaguers they're barely
squeaking it over the fence and they're
hitting in the last row and of course
you know it's been metal but that was
that was special but for me McCovey was
the guy I couldn't ever pitch to I had
no pitcher that could have a pitch to
get him out I mean I had every other
player I thought I could get out but not
with him not with my Cubs so you could
pitch the maze more than you couldn't
because oh sure yeah I mean Willie he
was all-time greatest he was you know
Willie was in 1960 I played my first
all-star game for in the Astrodome and
I'm sitting there in my locker
you know I was chosen as this ultimate
catch I was sitting in my locker you
know I'm not I got my feet tucked in I
don't want to trip anybody and here
since Willie right across from me and he
walks across the room he said you should
have been starting catching so then and
Willie and I got a offer all along
forever I don't know it was just a great
react and so he's down there and he's
got that swing going you know I stir
spreads out and he's got that hung and
everything else and I'm just sitting
there and he steps out after about eight
to ten swings I said you're gonna call a
pitcher what I said yes looking back
here swing his head back every time to
be going back and forth to see my side
often we're guys doing that oh you know
peanuts Lowry was the first base coach
for the Giants
every time he kind of even always tip
off pitches because every picture
basically tips if somebody's got his
glove he'll open it he'll do it squeeze
it he'll get the seams behind his back
so if peanuts called it you know called
a pitch and he had homerun peanuts got a
new suit was always trying to find
something to do it oh I mean if you tell
me what's coming I'll hit 700 I mean
that's the difference in what it makes
to know what's on the way wait so you
would want to know so oh boy yeah so if
somebody's at second base
like if Pete's at second base or Jill
Morgan's at second base would they
signal
no no they never did them cuz you get
beamed on that then they thought you
were stealing signs they throw it right
at your head I mean they didn't we
didn't mess around like you know some of
the guys know
they yeah you know they're leaning over
and strutting and looking at you know
they're standing there taking 32 seconds
to get around the bases oh they're going
down who went after you who really tried
to hit you aside from doc Ellis a junior
rich over laying those nasty 97 mile an
hour fastball 92 mile an hour slider and
I don't think you liked anybody you got
a hit off of him you know but Nolan Ryan
was that way to all those mean but you
just gave him respect you know Cal
Daniel's hit a home run off of him and
oh my gosh she was glaring at he was ran
on the bases next time up he gets a
double and burr Nolan's
an old hot so he turns it so he turns
around to pick off Daniels at second
base Cal wouldn't even leave he drilled
him and one of the great stories I was a
banquet one night bill Terry the old
batting champion yeah years ago he was a
manager and he told me about this young
kid he they called it from the minor
leagues and they're paying him like five
hundred dollars or something you know
say they bring a kid in he said if you
don't hit this guy coming up the plate
it's closer to your $50 I mean the kid
$50 I mean that's a lot so the guide
steps in kid winds up throws it goes
between his helmet and his head the guy
goes down at ball actually misses the
helmet and a it goes right between it
while the guys getting back up the
catcher's thrown the ball back the guy
hits the guy while he's getting up in
the batting spar Richards was underrated
too when you think of how nasty he was
oh that was he was 6 7 yeah nasty and I
mean and he would come inside and you
know you didn't lean over the plate did
you ever homer off Nolan Ryan I think I
did I think I should remember yeah I got
like seven or eight concussions so I
don't remember a lot of stuff did you
ever have somebody you thought serve one
up too you know because remember that
was the story with Denny McLain and
Mickey Mantle yeah that you know make
Denny would do that yeah where do you
want it it's pointed make it where you
want it and make big hit right here well
he's probably up ten to two or something
like that he's won 30 games already it's
not like they're going
anywhere but and when did you meet
mantle at a spring training game in 1966
I went on we got his autograph because
you're both from Oklahoma yeah and he
was you know he was it he was Mickey
Mantle that's what inspired me when I
was 3 years old to hear Mickey Mantle
batting and I said you can be from
Oklahoma and play in the major leagues I
was asking my dad and that's how I did
it and then he came to my I had a golf
tournament hearts the heart fund
Invitational in Tampa and he came to the
tournament and I had pictures on my wall
of him pitching pennies with my dad
outside the Ramada him and that night
Mickey comes up to me I'm staying over
there and he said hey John let's go have
a drink
Vicky's asked me to go have a drink
because it right across the street is
the Marriott and it's a disco you know
we got those back in those days it's
disco they got the glass balls and
everything else I said sure so we walked
across the street to the Marriott and we
walk up to the door the disco and a big
bouncer Zarin says John you can come in
but we've already kicked out how much
partying went on though back when you
pull out for us not much for us you guys
were that boring we were that
conscientious I think you know in spring
training when Sparky came he he gathered
all the guys around he said look alright
you twenty-five are going to Cincinnati
she said now there's two sets of rules
here
Pete Johnny toe Johnny you know you
don't have rules I'm thinking alright
you know even though we weren't staying
out I mean it was like but if you had a
something happen and you got you're fine
you don't have to sneak through the
kitchen do this stuff and then he said
rescue guys you're gonna do this this
and this and then he said and I think
this is something going on he said I
don't have to worry about those four
guys because they know what it takes
they know they'll be in they'll have
some time but they're gonna know what it
takes to win and it was just such a
psychological thing for us but we were
respected him we really we really didn't
I mean it was really a lot of times
after a game if you went to arrest on
her bar we you could take a team picture
because we all hung out together yeah
but no drinking I didn't say that
if you drink every day you're fine yeah
the guy it's the pitcher that pitches
you know drinks after the game where you
know in his I've got a problem yeah rest
of the [ __ ] I've had a problem if I had
an open draft right now and I you're
gonna start your Tim are you starting
with micro okay it would be second well
I really you know if I'm gonna go to
position players I really love Salvador
Perez you know as a catcher and what
he's I think the kid Realmuto
which is the kid from Miami that's not
getting any recognition at all I mean
he's hitting over 300 he's got home runs
he's got a 45 RBIs he's not getting and
I'm looking for a kid that will catch
and provide me offense as well I don't
think I think Buster Posey calls as good
a game as anybody in baseball right now
but I'm looking for a kid like Arenado
I'm looking for you know trout I'm gonna
probably forget are you a hard for fan
you know I I guess I admire his talents
I think he doesn't do it mechanically
the way he can I think he doesn't
utilize how much skill and talent he has
because you can't hit you can't be that
way and hit 215 yeah you know I mean I
can hit 23 home runs but that's when you
make contact but you know I want to pull
for him you know he's been a kid that's
been in the spotlight since he was 14 15
years old that's all we've heard about
and everything else and you know he but
the fans like him and that's that's what
really matters in a lot of ways yeah but
I've got to have production you know
I've got to have somebody like Tony
Perez that's gonna drive in the runs and
gets up there in a situation I want
Altuve at second base you know I'll take
you know I'll take Cory outs at
shortstop there's a lot of guys out
there and the Machado and and people
like that that I could build stuff
around but there's guys that have to
mesh and you know there's some there's
some great things going on with these
kids it will overlook some of them
aren't the names but we'll overlook
these how different would your career be
if you're playing now well I probably
wouldn't be here I'd probably be on a
jet and Al Capone course 500 million
yeah I mean you know let's face it
what's the most you ever made nine
hundred thousand okay yeah that was big
money back that was I made 2.2 in my
entire career so I was eleven thousand
my first year I was working here made 20
as MVP made 40 as MVP again I made 80 I
know it's big money okay I know what did
you do with all that I had I had I had
you know I had a lot of things so I mean
one that four days after I turned 25 I
had lung surgery I had part of my lung
taken out I had major surgery with a
which was the first staple surgery in
America and then I got ran over in 75
and it damaged my AC joint and crushed
that I had six cortisone shots every
three weeks to finish remover Gary
Matthews who peed through a 17 hopper in
from left field and so and we laugh
about it all the time I would run on
Pete yeah yeah yeah I wouldn't be afraid
to run on Pete Rose now but he got me
with a forum and that was in April I had
six cortisone shots every three weeks to
finish the season and so you know I but
after this lung surgery I wasn't the
same player I wasn't nearly as you know
what I would thought I was hurt but most
you hit was 45 homers I'm sorry yeah
yeah well Erin never hit 50 no in that
amazing that is I mean really truly
remarkable that the guy with that many
home runs never hit 50 and you know if
he took away 755 homeruns he still had
3,000 his oh I think he's the most
underrated player in baseball you know
what because he didn't have it he didn't
have the Mays he didn't have the mantle
I mean if you look at him and people
talk about look how their bodies change
well you know Hank was 165 or 70 pounds
when he went to you know play with
Boston and Milwaukee whatever it was he
had his wrist though
oh and he'd lean out there and in he was
the kindest gentleman yes and then you
but you never saw it until he walked up
to the plate and then you saw the
forearms
you had so you're catching when he ties
Babe Ruth homerun record rights right so
Billington Jack Billingham is on the
road good is okay do you remember the
pitch you called that he hit out it was
a little fastball out over the plate
okay well I shook his hand at home play
oh you did I you know he he never failed
to say hello to me
the first at-bat hi John hello Amy
and to this day we still hi John hello
Henry did you understand what was going
on at the time where death threats no no
with with Hank and the fact that
Commissioner made him like didn't he
have a problem he wanted him to set the
record in Atlanta yeah Bowie Kuhne say
yeah I want you to go and set the record
in Atlanta and then of course the first
and then we held him you know we held
him but another story about Hank is I
was in center field and fielded his
3,000th hit no I didn't know that I
caught the first game of the
doubleheader
he went over for and I played
centerfield in the second game and he
had a ball up the middle that I filled
it I why I didn't keep that ball I can't
keep if I had all of the current Hall of
Famers and I said one time vote for Pete
to be in the Hall of Fame if I if I had
everybody right now or put him on the
ballot what do you think the current
Hall of Famers would vote no not even
put him on the ballot no okay well you
know the story is and you know but we
should make it in Commissioner of
baseball gambling I mean if they're you
know if it sounds a so ridiculous but if
they're gonna start gambling in baseball
maybe do it but the thing that is it I
tell people is people who say yes that
he should be then I say do you have kids
and they said yeah and I said well go
home and tell your kids there's no more
rules and you know it kind of like makes
you think about what it is now the the
thing that upsets all of us is that he
had a chance yeah the first year you
know the first day when nuber off gave
him the option of signing a paper and he
said if you don't sign this and Jimmy
Giamatti is going to nail you and that's
the way it happened but
I had three different meetings with the
commissioners with with with a seagull
and bud and I said look so we gave him
it was we wrote it out they had it
written out miss Schmidt Ian and Morgan
and I and had it written out do this do
this do this and you'll be you know you
have a little time and then put you on
them but it didn't happen yeah no and
and all he had to do he had to show
contrition and give back
imagine if he went to them all the minor
leagues and just said I'm gonna tour the
minor leagues for baseball and talk
about what I just I just did do I have
career suicide and if he did that I
really feel like he would have that was
the oyster hall-of-famers that was one
of the offers there what else did they
ask Pete to do he had to admit it but he
had to go away and he had to stop and he
had to admit to what he was doing
and he had you know say I did this and I
did that and I admit to it meeting great
Johnny is what is keeping it has kept
like he refused to give in to anybody
right oh yeah he said I'm gonna beat it
mmm here we are
yeah do you think he gets in
posthumously I don't know I'll probably
be dead by then - I don't know all right
I I'll let you know how it goes cuz I
[Laughter]
when they bring out the cuff and put it
around it's great to see you thank you
for stopping by
make it fun for all we appreciate thank
you he's Johnny Bench the best catcher
in baseball history thank you at least
in my opinion thank you well the last
century anyways yeah are you the best
catcher ever I don't I think I am okay
who's second you know I I y'all
surprised you with I think Carlton Fisk
okay
he might agree - sure you know cuz
somebody else a he said that on the
radio
I can't believe you sleep why would he
say did you call the pitch from Darcy
that Fisk it out for the calendar paddy
pitch the 11th inning and threw a really
great 11th inning and he went out to
warm up in the 12th and it was like Dan
I got to tell you you would have thrown
it harder and I mean I was like reaching
out for it and I looked over in the
dugout to Sparky and I said no chance
we're not going any farther than this
inning really I said no chance I said I
don't care who it was and the greatness
of the game was that Carlton did it
that was another way it happened it
wasn't Korea it was down and you could
have probably hit it off the wall now
but and then he do all this gyrations
and do you know that was one of the
first drama things I think in so many
ways I mean we've seen Mazeroski running
with the helmet around there and we've
seen things but when Carlton did this
and it actually hit the pole you
couldn't have scripted it more because
during that game Bernie carbo hits a
three-run pinch-hit homer that ties the
game up they got at the bottom of the
ninth they got the bases loaded
they bring we bring in will McEnaney he
crosses me up I call for a slider he
throws a fastball I don't know if I'll
catch him he fouls it off goes down the
left-field line George Foster throws a
one hopper to me I'd tag him out Denny
Doyle
there's Denny's on third you know and
here's Don Zimmer going no no no and any
thought I said go any I tagged him out
and ice called timeout and I grabbed
will I said well for God's sake you
crossed me up I gave you the slider side
and a left-handed reliever is only could
do it and says yeah I guess I did well
sometimes those things work and then
Dwight Dwight Evans made that great
tangible that was one of the greatest
catches I've ever seen but you got your
hellos yeah thanks for having me thank
you buddy
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you